this video is brought to you by g-fuel
off the back of the last arc the tuning
exams i was ready to dive into more
material almost immediately and just
like last week with the completion of
this week's batch of manga volumes i can
finally admit that the story of naruto
has defeated me i now want to read the
series all the time and because of that
i now fear the day that will eventually
inevitably come or i will have to stop
reading naruto the first arc acted as a
brilliant introduction to the
character's themes and familiarized
myself with kishimoto in a way that
heightened my enjoyment the second arc
elevated all of that material in ways
that felt both natural and exciting
while uncovering a lasting evil in the
series but in this arc the scope of
naruto exploded with more characters
lore and potential than i ever
anticipated i think i'm finally starting
to understand why naruto became the
cultural icon it is today
[Applause]
a main feature of this story and indeed
its world since i began covering it has
been the hokage their history what they
represent what they've done and who will
next be selected as the fifth hokage
given that the fourth died long before
this series began in a battle to save
the earth and that the third is now very
old and sort of in the clutches of
orochimaru facing almost certain death
the selection of the fifth hokage is up
in the air and of vital importance to
secure the village's future and thus are
the circumstances and stakes heading
into this video's material and speaking
of which i think this might be the best
opening an arc has received since i
started reading effectively the world
naruto's grown up in is suddenly plunged
into chaos and ruin while the first two
arcs land of waves and the tuning exams
began in absolute stability this one
begins in utter chaos the very best of
the best are being backed up against the
wall all the while naruto sakura and
shikamaru are being ordered to chase
after sasuke to stop him from
overextending himself with the expressed
order that once they achieve their
assignment they need to wait for further
instructions i can only imagine the
anxiety that would flow through me if i
was assigned something like that
effectively being asked to run from home
on a rescue mission of sorts not knowing
if i'll ever return to see my community
in the same state ever again there's
such unbelievably high stakes with the
entire infrastructure of this world
hanging in the balance it's such an
unbelievably effective
attention-grabbing opener that flows
brilliantly from the abrupt conclusion
to the tuning exams prior furthermore i
can absolutely appreciate why pursuing
gara is immensely important to the likes
of sasuke on a narrative level and it
all ties back to his foundational
motivations from the first and second
chapters sasuke's expressed interest
before the tuning exams even began was
to fight worthy adversaries to increase
his strength and proficiency as a ninja
this is to of course accomplish his one
goal to kill his brother knowing that
his brother is much stronger than him
sasuke needs to be as sure as he can
possibly be once he does eventually
track him down that he has the strength
to do what he wants and so gara is a new
focus why because gara is the first
training ninja in the history of the
exams to finish the forest of death in
that time frame and without sustaining
any damage in other words gaara at this
point is stronger than sasuke's brother
was when he underwent this challenge of
course assuming he underwent this
challenge and so proving to himself that
he can defeat gara is a great indicator
of how strong sasuke is relative to his
brother at this point in his life and
the eventual pursuit of sasuke by the
likes of naruto shikamaru and sakura is
really fun incorporating a diverse
number of characters not limited to gara
himself eventually but of the battles
leading up to that effort shikamaru's is
the best i think working in a very
similar fashion to his prior conflict
during the tuning exams against another
of the sand village's best and brightest
he's really won me over with his relaxed
laid-back and calculated approach to
everything formulating a plan of action
in seconds against the pursuing bad guys
all within a frenzied panic furthermore
shikomaru during this sequence brought
to my attention an in-universe
explanation that excuses for me one of
the most irritating aspects of modern
and classic anime with this shadow
possessing power there's now an
in-universe reason for people to stand
around blustering and talking their
hearts out with no action thanks to his
special shadow ability but that's not
the only fight that starts taking place
towards the beginning of this section
it's time
for you
when i first started reading this fight
one of the things i didn't expect to
show its face were the levels of
sentimentality it ended up brandishing
there are some powerful moments of
reflection on behalf of hirosen himself
with his confrontations against his
resurrected masters all the while he's
forced to contend with his one time star
pupil orochimaru and when you lay out
the material like that it's easy to see
the obvious opportunities for emotional
connection but the way this fight paces
itself and dishes out fascinating
exposition both about orochimaru as a
child his relationships with hirozen and
of course the history of heroes that
himself as a youth you can't help but
feel that much more invested and
connected to these characters not to
mention the world they're involved with
the story in question is called naruto
but this fight while having little to
nothing to do with that character stands
on its own two feet and breathes new
life into the story the action itself
although feeling less like ninjutsu now
and more like elemental bending on the
skill of avatar the last airbender
provides more spectacle than pretty much
anything we've seen before this point
and it reminded me of how old hirozen
really must be now like many different
stories both from the east and the west
the older mentor character is a
stereotype that depicts someone as
decrepit one moment while in another
moment showing everyone else up in
naruto while this is still somewhat true
with this character it doesn't
romanticize the toll aging has had on
the great third hokage with time itself
and the passage of it being a major
focus of this conflict between these two
characters orochimaru breaking
established rules and laws extending his
youth beyond what is natural and hirusen
accepting his decline fighting better
than anyone we've ever seen in the
series forced to fight and defeat his
former masters the first and second
hokages all the while taking out
orochimaru as a threat albeit at the
cost of his own life it's clearly an
emotionally charged affair given that at
first he's mostly on the defensive which
orochimaru points out at the beginning
is really unlike him it's honestly a
remarkable show of force that helps to
put into perspective how absurdly
powerful he must have been in his prime
given that this is him now taking some
of orochimaru's absolute best and while
he does die losing the battle he secures
the safety of those around him for the
time being eliminating orochimaru's
ability to weave signs thus in essence
winning the war the most effective and i
think perhaps the most important aspect
looking to the future concerning this
fight however might be that of what we
learn about orochimaru in these flashes
to the past how he was hoping to be the
fourth hokage and failed in meeting the
requirements and now he seeks to have
all the knowledge of all the different
styles granting himself eternal youth in
the process overall from an aesthetics
perspective this fight was visually
beautiful in the manga and in the anime
the animation only served to elevate
that material i particularly enjoyed the
back and forth hirozin had with his
former masters the special effects
animation on display for mudslides fire
and water there's so much stunning
movement coating that episode i do
however have one small criticism of this
fight while it's perfectly natural for
orochimaru to remain something of an
unknown going into this encounter
heruzen the third hokage felt still
unfamiliar to me despite his presence in
the beginning of this story and due to
this the narrative had to dedicate
substantial sections to exploring
hirozen as well as onojimaru that's not
a deal breaker at all however and what
narrative exposition there is i still
relatively enjoyed i mean the entire
purpose of this fight at the end of the
day was to give us a history lesson and
build up the world further so it
succeeded in that effort crescendoing on
a powerful and intense moment as the
third hokage sacrifices himself to rid
the world of a great evil one last time
protecting the people he cares for
deeply by removing orochimaru's
abilities which i am only now realizing
is another very similar narrative move
to avatar the last airbender i'm getting
a feeling they might have taken some
notes from naruto in this respect and
while this fight did bookend this
section of the story the real meat of
the conflict proving to have spectacle
to rival that of even the hokage level
threat here was that of naruto versus
gara
naruto vs gara the showdown between gara
and the various characters that try to
stop him is brilliant beginning with the
closest in pursuit of the young man
sasuke our favorite little moody boy and
their dynamic is interesting for me
mainly because it's between two people
with hateful motivations sasuke attempts
his third and possible suicidal attack
willing to throw his life away at the
chance to proceed ever closer to his one
single-minded goal all the while gara a
once small reserved child now more
closely resembles a monster grotesque
his body phase and being contorts to
form an accurate representation of the
hatred and suffering inside his mind i
like that in making this decision sasuke
began to once again succumb to the curse
of orochimaru and just as he is being
overcome by it and facing the finishing
blow from this new monstrous gara naruto
makes the save with this save being
perhaps metaphorical or emblematic of
what's to come for sasuke and naruto
that naruto will in the future save him
from himself and once naruto arrives we
recognize that exact same conflict cloud
his mind and caused that very same
hesitancy only once before have we seen
naruto freeze up and since then it's
been pretty smooth sailing the source of
his determination and bravery has always
been that regardless of the opponent he
knows that he's willing to go further to
push himself more than they are and to
him at this point in his life that's all
he has he doesn't believe in or rely on
what comes naturally to him like sasuke
does and he doesn't believe in his
intelligence the same way sakura or
shikamaru would and really it's easy to
see why he's never been told to believe
in those facets of himself and as a
result has only tested himself in the
realms of his own determination he wants
to achieve his goals so badly that he's
willing to push himself farther than
anyone he knows that's where his
confidence comes from and that
specifically is what makes gara an
interesting and imposing character for
naruto to face consumed by the demon
inside him naruto is not only facing
someone who he knows is willing to die
fighting willing to struggle as hard as
he will but he's also face to face with
a manifestation of a reality that could
have been his own and in many ways still
could be like gara he has a demon inside
of him and this fear causes him to
hesitate further putting his friends in
danger the seeds for this encounter were
sown in the prior arc as we slowly began
to understand who gara was and what he
was all about and with this final
showdown between two sides of
effectively the same coin
we got another perspective having been
depicted as a monster and showing all of
his personality defects we receive a
flashback to gara's past and in it the
first panel displays gara sitting on a
swing alone looking on as other kids age
are having fun
remind you of anyone the flashback
itself is short but it certainly paints
a lonely tragic and harrowing picture of
what it must have been like asgara
growing up in a world that both feared
and despised him coming to a head with
the only person in his life choosing to
make an attempt on his own life marking
the point where he would become the
person he is today the reasons i love
battle shonen as a genre are numerous
however as i was watching this climactic
final battle between two giant kaiju in
a ninja themed story about believing in
yourself i was reminded of one specific
reason the genre allows you to place
incredible philosophical symbolic or
thematic weight behind the various
techniques that are implemented in it to
show you what i mean i'll use dragon
ball as an example given that it's the
story i'm most familiar with towards the
beginning of dragon ball z the events of
the saiyan saga get underway goku dies
his sons kidnapped by his arch nemesis
and aliens invade and take over the
world it's pretty standard stuff and
just like this arc naruto where we see a
giant frog slice a sand monster with a
sword the visuals and craziness of the
saiyan saga what with its giant monkey
monsters massive beam struggles and
depiction of the afterlife gave it more
than enough eye candy to put on a wild
show but the reason that this arc was
successful had much more to do with the
simple story that was being told at its
foundation and how the actions of the
main characters reflected the
philosophies that they represented when
vegeta arrives he doesn't show affection
for his allies or anyone really in fact
he kills his oldest comrade the second
he's no longer useful to him in this way
vegeta acts as the opposite of what goku
represents in the story having given up
his life at the beginning of the arc to
save literally everyone goku travels to
otherworld and after exerting more
effort than any mortal in history across
snake way requests the help of someone
he has never met so that he can continue
to defend others and once he touches
down on the battlefield having been
brought back by his friends he finds
himself as the one thing standing
between everything he cares about and
certain annihilation all with the
technique that he managed to acquire
thanks to the philosophy he believed in
in this way battle shonen has
facilitated not only a beam struggle but
a struggle of ideology between ego and
humility the beam struggle wasn't a
cornerstone moment in a battle that has
gone down in history as one of the
greatest of all times simply because it
looked visually interesting absolutely
not it's because of what it represents
and so across the series techniques like
the spirit bomb kaioken and kamehameha
didn't just look cool through their
acquisition or connection to the story
they each represented a part of goku's
identity and in that same way during
this battle with gara naruto's
philosophy and way of life is challenged
directly by his natural opposite ingara
and to combat this natural opposing
threat naruto uses the techniques that
represent who he is and what makes him a
terrific character after overcoming the
initial shock that came from confronting
a demented and psychotic version of
himself early on in the conflict a tried
and true means of building up tension to
a big reveal took place gara would knock
naruto to the floor berating him and
poking what he saw as holes in his
idealistic and hopeful outlook on life
but time and time again naruto would
stand back up and as i pointed out in
his flashback governor's struggle has
been about his lack of belief in other's
ability to love him he refuses to trust
in anyone and so lives only for himself
hurting others maybe before they had the
chance to hurt him there are numerous
stages where gara slips up and naruto
manages to land a significant hit before
he eventually runs out of chakra to help
any more and realizing this sasuke
stands up for him and tries to create an
opening to allow both him and sakura to
escape in response to this
naruto throws out a beautiful quote
when people are protecting someone truly
precious to them they truly can become
as strong as they must be all the while
assuming the same pose he did when he
was standing up for iruka in chapter one
naruto explodes with chakra resulting in
a very similar scene and page spread
this is the technique that represents
the love his friends have for him and
the love he has for them it's the
manifestation of naruto's desire to
protect those he loves the perfect
thematic counter to gara's hateful and
lonely perspective that's haunted him
his entire life but that's not even the
best part as i said there's a giant frog
versus giant sand monster kaiju battle
and even here this same narrative
approach is present with stunning
effectiveness i would even argue to
greater effect as gara makes decisions
that make this contrast even more
pronounced naruto's summoning of
gamabunta is a very important touch
kishimoto added to make this picture as
effective as it ends up being if we want
to break this down kemabunta and
naruto's ability to summon him in the
first place is directly tied to the fox
spirit's chakra which was only now
possible to access thanks to jiraiya
granting naruto the agency to make his
own destiny by removing the seal that
blocked this chakra naruto now summons
gamabunta because he has the control to
make the fox spirit work for him which
happens to be the exact opposite of
gara's ace in the hole wherein he
effectively surrenders all the agency he
has to the sand spirit by falling
unconscious thus unlocking the full
power of this spirit and so when
described like that the scene while we
can acknowledge on a surface level how
much is visually happening on screen i
mean come on look there's a giant frog
wearing clothes and a sword while it has
a lot going on if you look at what this
story is about it becomes much more
simple and effective it's not just a
crazy monster battle with the fate of
the known world on the line it's naruto
using the good that he's received in his
life to try and reach gara someone
that's fallen so far from reality and
boy does naruto reach him
this is the natural end to the major
conflict of this arc with gara out for
the count destruction after coming to an
end in their village and the hukage
after losing his life during the battle
with orochimaru the progression into the
next arc feels seamless something i've
criticized dragon ball super in the past
for was how little the arks themselves
flowed into each other everything felt
as though it had a clearly defined and
cut ending which can be okay for some
people but for me i much prefer when the
events of the prior story inform the
next it creates a believable cause and
effect and furthermore injects a great
sense of scale to the occasion and this
is true for naruto in this instance for
everything that's transpired it's the
consequences of the prior arc that
informed the events of this one
is such a lovely character quirky and
light from the beginning i saw a very
naruto sort of energy within him
reinforced perfectly in this section by
the imagery of his training days and
it's this position the fifth hokage
looking to be filled that this arc most
concerns itself with this upcoming arc
concerns itself with answering
predominantly two questions what does it
mean to be hokage and who will be the
fifth and on this journey we follow
jiraiya and naruto as they set out to
find tsunade one of the three great
shinobi touted by jiraiya himself as
being perfect for the job the story
feels well thought out and the events
within it are thrilling so let's jump
into it
we tend to run at least one ad a week on
this channel to support the production
of these videos it allows me to do what
i love and i get to employ the wonderful
people behind the scenes who help keep
things running smoothly make my life
much easier and in turn make these
videos much better for you guys the
companies we work with on these ads tend
to send us a massive list of talking
points and while we'll always touch on
the ones we believe in and support it
can get very tiresome and we seldom get
to be creative g-fuel are a huge
exception to this rule not once have
they ever given us any kind of brief
they leave everything up to us and as
i'm sure you've noticed that's resulted
in the most extravagant and fun content
we've ever made for sponsors i mean they
let us make an ad where i dressed as
jesus sprinkled their g-fuel formula
onto a man's pregnant wife turning her
into a bunch of g-fuel products i got to
parody harry potter and rename ruby as
hagrid to pewdies energy grid we've done
the most ridiculous ludicrous stuff and
they have been nothing but supportive
and because of this i would love to keep
working with them and that of course
hinges on how well these ads perform so
if you love these kooky skits and you're
interested in legitimately delicious
energy drinks and i do mean legitimate
they are delicious click the link in the
description and grab some today they're
a household name for a reason and i hope
you enjoy their stuff as much as i do
but
[Music]
is
during their travels to find tsunade
gives naruto specific training that is
quite advanced it involves chakra
manipulation in three separate steps i
found this section very fun but within
it i began to realize something recently
in the story it's felt at least from an
optical point of view from other
characters that naruto has undergone a
fairly significant change a sudden
realization has occurred that he is in
fact destined not for mediocrity but
instead something significant it flips
the script on the character in a sense
but i don't necessarily think in a bad
way the journey from his birth through
the land of waves all the way through to
the end of the tuning exams has been in
many ways completed he was an insecure
kid without a place in the world and
through great hardship overcame any
falsehood he may have believed either
about himself or others his goal to
become the next chokage while still
unachieved it was a goal set by him to
show the world that not only is some
loser kid worth something but is capable
of achieving the highest rank in the
land in other words he was determined to
make something of himself despite what
others might have thought but with his
travels having yielded surprising
changes in his mindset and outlook as
seen during the gara fight he now has no
reason to have such a chip on his
shoulder he's proven himself not only
strong to the people who care about him
but most importantly himself and so
strictly speaking in a sense this
emotional journey for him as a character
is over he spent the entire story trying
to prove his worth and reliability to
various people in his life and now that
he has that kishimoto then decided to
give him more promise and responsibility
than any other character in the series
[Music]
hello do you have a moment to talk about
our lord and savior
for the entire series naruto has wanted
to be this person and now we get to see
how he fares when the crippling pressure
of this responsibility becomes a reality
and he would have lost died or had been
taken away by itachi had it not been for
the likes of sasuke coming to save him
or eventually jiraiya and thus one of
the main takeaways from this encounter
ends up being naruto once again
wasn't ready the poor kid was just about
figuring out how the world as he knew it
worked growing up and now everything is
suddenly changing however thankfully the
last few arcs have helped him grow and
unlike last time he found himself unsure
he has something and someone to fight
for
the training that naruto undergoes has
specific emphasis on this philosophy to
find self-reliance and master a
technique in stages with as little help
as possible jiraiya totally aware of
this forces naruto to self-soothe and
teach himself offering up a collection
of scenes that feel both intimate and
enlightening for us as an audience to
sit back and watch seeing his struggles
his injuries and flashes back into the
past to gain deeper insight into the
workings of what he's doing was
wonderful to experience seeing his doubt
his frustration and the pain he goes
through to achieve this frankly
incredible feat in such a short amount
of time stands in direct contrast with
the likes of goku who seem to manage
incredible feats of strength with
comparative ease these training
sequences with jiraiya highlight
something integral to the progression of
this character and really this story i
think for me it highlights or rather
points out that despite the shift in
value people now see in naruto with him
effectively being a great significance
he's still the same kid struggling and
trying his best to succeed against all
of this pressure and that's really what
this entire second half following the
death of the third hokage is about
responsibility and how different
characters with different backgrounds
react to sudden or long-existing
responsibility orochimaru and in a
smaller way for now itachi are the
forces of pressure being applied to this
world forcing as i've explained the
likes of naruto to improve and train but
these themes are also explored with the
likes of jiraya and even tsunade to
meaningful degrees with the position of
fifth hokage requiring someone to fill
it both jiraya and tsunade are faced
with that responsibility jiraya almost
immediately shifts the responsibility to
tsunade and in doing that is forced to
accept the responsibility of training
naruto and locating tsunare who he
thinks is a better fit speaking of which
tsunami on the other hand is a much more
interesting character with this line of
thought while jiraya made his decision
based on little more than his own
assessment of him not being right for
the job tsunade is faced with the
dilemma of which his options directly
conflict with each other save the
village by becoming the fifth hokage or
assure the village's destruction by
helping orochimaru and to be honest
there's no more interesting character to
force this dilemma upon than her from
the moment we hear about her to the
moment we meet her were painted a
picture of a person who just runs away
from responsibility only living for
herself and what she wants and now she's
faced with what would effectively be
something she can never turn back from
and in exchange for denying the
responsibility that comes with being the
fifth hokage orochimaru offers an
alternative to reanimate her loved ones
this obviously represents the ultimate
want in her life and so when she's faced
with the offer of responsibility the
fifth hokage comes with she immediately
declines much to naruto's astonishment
and anger further emphasized by her
dismissal of the fourth hokage sacrifice
citing it as a foolhardy thing to have
done
this was such a satisfying scene a clash
of two literal opposing ideologies one
who is willing to do anything to achieve
the status of hokage and one who thinks
it's pointless punctuated by a short but
philosophically rich fight outside one
word tsunade chose not to use more than
her fingernail and to great effect she
uses it but and this is the best part
the responsibility naruto represents in
this conflict makes itself known through
the technique he's been training the
responsibilities that he's adopted
during this training session the
technique that represents this
responsibility shocked tsunade and gives
her an idea let naruto train one week
and if he can master the rosengan she'll
say he's deserving of becoming hokage in
addition to giving him her grandfather's
necklace and if he fails she takes all
his money what makes this timeline
specifically interesting is that it also
happens to coincide with the time
orochimaru wants an answer to his offer
from tsunare the means with which these
two stories narutos as well as tsunamis
intertwine and inform each other is both
natural and fascinating there's a
wonderful scene where tsunade's friend
shizune brings naruto and us up to speed
concerning tsunami's tragic past filled
with loss and terror seeing this allows
us to empathize much more readily with
her but for naruto it only invigorates
him right before she tells naruto about
her backstory he complains that she's
stopping him from getting the rest he
needs to train tomorrow however after
this conversation he informs her that
he's going off the train immediately
this search for tsunade section of the
story is the absolute best naruto has
been for me as both a reviewer and a fan
of shonen storytelling over the first
115 chapters while they did shine a
light on the themes of determination and
responsibility they were never the focus
quite like they are in this arc because
naruto is such a brilliantly fleshed out
and fully realized character instead of
having to dedicate time within the story
to serve his character to bolster these
traits his character can now be used to
service the story for this reason to
represent the themes of determination
and responsibility and in using him this
way kishimoto managed to help me build a
powerful connection and relationship
with the character of tsunade throughout
this arc she's been quite honestly a
turbulent character one that's caused a
tremendous amount of conflict in the
story and in this final portion she
confronts orochimaru and she decides to
take the more difficult option in the
face of everything orochimaru is
offering she says
no
and that journey from feeling
indifferent or ambivalent to feeling
true responsibility for not just herself
or her friends but for her entire
village she feels a responsibility to
become what they need her to be and
right here you can feel as though the
story is building up to a specific point
to something special naruto certainly
plays his role in this battle by
demonstrating the value of self-belief
determination and responsibility in the
face of certain doom and in doing so
like he has shown hints of at numerous
points in the series despite performing
incredible feats that pale in comparison
to the power kabuto possesses he manages
to inspire belief in these ideas for
those around him and that's when we see
that all the focus and effort that
kishimoto has put into the story
converge into one point a point that he
has built up
and it's this
this moment honestly gave me chills to
have an entire arc a character has
undergone be so succinctly punctuated
and presented in one sentence all the
while demonstrating in such a visually
stunning way kishimoto sir fantastic
work from this point on the rest is
action movie window dressing but even so
the battle with their summon spirits
with all three of the shinobi greats was
intense and satisfying
[Music]
i loved watching orochimaru getting beat
in the end too by the way but really it
was the quieter moments that have stayed
with me in this story more than anything
else
there's a minor visual gag during this
material that i knew had a lot of
potential for emotional resonance
tsunade's insistence on appearing young
using her chakra to manipulate the way
she looks changing herself from a
50-something year old woman to one that
looks as though she's in her 20s i
thought that this was an interesting
idea for two reasons firstly i liked
that it immediately helped to reveal
what sort of temperament she had and
where her values lay but also because i
thought it reflected her character's
biggest flaw the story of tsunare is one
of a troubled soul trapped in the past
filled with resentment unable to move on
from the horrible losses she suffered
during that part of her life i thought
it served as a brilliant metaphor for
her current mindset and beliefs in the
beginning of this part of the story and
when the ending came that powerful
realization and life-altering shifting
mindset so too did her barriers for
throwing her life away for a cause worth
the sacrifice and symbolically after
exhausting herself completely in a
desperate and powerful effort to save
everyone and rise up to become the fifth
hokage her illusion fell revealing her
actual self free of illusion it's a
beautiful touch that really sealed this
as such a phenomenal arc for me it was
simple had a clear message and was
powerful in its execution in essence it
was focused it managed to harness
everything i loved about this story and
in the process created a fantastic
character that happened to be female
i've been vocal about my issues with the
likes of eno and sakura but i'm also
willing to point out a job well done
when i see it tsunade is a great
character that had a brilliant arc in
the story and with the fifth hokage now
after being selected and accepted
orochimaru's still on the run and a
massive world of possibilities ahead i
can confidently say that i am thrilled i
picked up this series and i cannot wait
to see what lies ahead of us on this
wild and inspirational adventure be sure
to subscribe if you want to see more
reviews of naruto like this and if you
don't want to miss an upload but until
then i've been totally not mark i'll see
you all next week and thank you so much
for watching
[Music]
oh